[Music]
philip jose
farmers novella the lovers
is a kind of notorious
story in science fiction there's a lot
of you could call it
legendarium and lore about its important
place
in particular breaking taboos
about sex in science fiction now what
does that
actually mean and is that really the
case
or is that something that people say and
then other people
pick up on that and everybody keeps
saying that there's a number of ways we
can
approach this one is by looking at the
field of science fiction and perhaps
even expanding it to
fantasy and horror and other speculative
fiction
um you know closely related genres and
saying well what's what's the status
with sex in that prior to the lovers and
that's one thing
that will do another is to actually read
the
novella rather than simply accepting
what other people have to say about it
and
see how much sex there actually is
in it and then when you do that you
start making
important differentiations about what do
we mean by
sex in science fiction what what
different kinds or ways of bringing up
or referencing or using sex
are there and then perhaps in some of
those ways farmers
work could be quite astounding the other
thing that i think you can do
is to look at reviews both contemporary
and a little bit
later of this work and see whether
people were
so absolutely astounded by it and saying
the veil has dropped from our eyes
now we can actually talk about these
these topics that we've kept submerged
for so long i didn't know we could do
that or whether
it's a little bit you know more mundane
you know positive reactions mostly but
uh not quite so over the top
and let's remind ourselves a little bit
about the
history right um so this is a
a story that gets published originally
in a shorter form
that has you know more of the lover
aspect
or at least the same amount of the lover
aspect as in the later
version and a little bit less of the
world building involved it gets
published
in startling stories in 1952
and then expanded in 1963 with more
material more
world building which is actually quite
excellent
in this story about the starch
back on earth the uh the whole religion
and philosophy and way of life
associated with the hijack alliance
and the world of oz again
and the different species that are
living there
so that's something important to keep in
mind we're talking about
early 50s a lot of people associate the
1950s with
you know across the board sexual
repression
as many people mistakenly also do with
victorians but all you have to do is
read some of the other literature
of the time to realize that that really
wasn't quite the case
there's this trope of breaking the taboo
and we need to think about what that
means does that mean that
there wasn't any actual sex in sci-fi
that it was just something not only
not allowed but you couldn't even talk
about the
not being allowed or was it that there
were certain lines that you weren't
supposed to cross
and they varied from place to place
whatever we can say you know the
response to the lovers was
generally quite positive if there really
was a strong taboo
you would have expected to see it
decried from the rooftops and the
pulpits and
pick whatever else you want that didn't
happen
instead it gets a hugo award in 1953
so clearly the science fiction community
likes what it's seeing
and it gets a lot of praise in in you
know some there's some criticism not
all of the criticism has anything to do
with sex some of it is just you know we
didn't like the story
so let's think about this idea of the
taboo
now this is you know a word that we use
in our contemporary parlance to mean
some sort of prohibition
or to say that it's the things we don't
talk about
right and was there really a taboo
against sex in science fiction
or in speculative fiction more broadly
you know if you were to go and look at
the
pulp sci-fi covers you sure wouldn't
think that there was any sort of taboo
because one of the favorite thing of
pulp artists
is to have a nearly naked woman often
in you know rather revealing or
suggestive
postures front and center
on the cover sometimes being menaced by
a monster sometimes being saved
sometimes you know kissing the hero all
sorts of things like sometimes being the
threat herself right
so you know sci-fi covers we could say
well
don't judge a book by its cover or a
magazine for that matter
maybe the the covers are much more
graphic
and the contents are a lot tamer and
that that generally was
the case but i would suggest that you
actually take a look
at some of those covers to get an idea
about whether sex was on the mind of
anybody
in reading or writing or editing
these these stories and i think the
answer is yes
we also can see that the lovers is
definitely not the first
science fiction story in the 20th
century where sex
is referenced or even thematized
and you know we can think of some pretty
famous examples
um is uh you know if we want to think
about
is apocalyptic or utopian or dystopian
fiction something
different from sci-fi or do they overlap
to some degree
if they overlap brave new world
right definitely talked about in there
i would say even thematized as a central
part of
the society being depicted there um we
could also talk about
you know cl moore's very famous shamblo
and some of her other stories as well
in that time we could think of plenty of
other authors all of stapleton has
has you know people having sex in his
stories
so you know cs lewis obviously is
referencing it in his his uh
space trilogy in that hideous strength
is there really a taboo
in the sense of like an across-the-board
moral prohibition clearly not
i guess we could talk about the degree
to which sex
is in fact being referenced
how are we getting descriptions of
people we get lots of descriptions
of people in terms of what might be
called their bodily characteristics that
pertain to sex lots of descriptions of
women's figures and the virility of men
maybe they're not actually having sex
although there's lots of other scenes as
well where they kiss and then you know
basically fade to black and we know
what's coming next right
sometimes they're having kids so
i don't think that we can say that
there's anything
that's really a taboo
in a strong sense but why is this coming
up then well we should actually
think about the lovers what's going on
in there
there are actual descriptions about
what's going on
if you're looking to the lovers for
erotic prose
you are not going to find it there uh it
it's there's really
you know there's a few discussions of
sex scenes but
it's you know pretty literary pretty
short
pretty in one respect clinical
at the start and i'm going to read a few
of them for you so you can get an idea
so
hal um is is having sex with mary
as as is his duty and it's kind of a
you know unfun thing so uh mary is so
shocked she could not reply
and turned her back to him but he
knowing that he was doing it as much to
punish her
and himself as doing what he should
reached out for her from then on having
made the formal opening statement
everything was ritualized
this time unlike sometimes in the past
everything was executed step by step the
words and actions
except one detail hal was still wearing
his day clothes
i mean if you didn't know that the the
ritual is them having sex
you wouldn't you wouldn't suspect it
would you'd be like well maybe they're
making muffins or something a little bit
later
uh in the next chapter he says
afterward laying on his back staring
into the darkness hal thought as he had
many times before was what was it that
cut through his abdomen like a broad
thick steel plate
and seemed to sever his torso from his
hips he was excited in the beginning he
knew he must be because his heart beat
fast he breathed hard
yet he could not really feel anything
and when the moment came
he experienced only a mechanical action
his body carried out its prescribed
function but he felt
nothing of that ecstasy which the
forerunner had described so
vividly a zone of unfeeling a nerve
chilling area a steel plate cut through
him
he felt nothing except the jerkings of
his body
as if an electrical needle was
stimulating his nerves at the same time
as it numbed them
right so you know this is a
very unsexy reaction um he's
he's kind of like dead from the waist
down when it comes to things because of
his sexual repression
a little bit later we get a description
uh this is in chapter eight
of him seeing uh the woman who's to
become his lover
um here we go he stepped closer and
flushed with the heat of embarrassment
almost he turned and ran her white skin
was relieved only by
two black narrow strips of cloth one
across her breast the other
diapered about the hips it was a sight
such as he'd never seen in his life
except in a forbidden photograph and
then
then he sees that she's got lipstick and
he's like wow this is this is really
something here and so he's um you know
he's reacting to her
nearly naked body basically wearing what
would be the equivalent of a
bikini or a bra and underwear
a little bit later
in the work when they are actually
becoming
lovers we get a bit of description that
i guess
could be racy for some people right
they're kissing
they kissed and ran their hands over
each other and said the things lovers
have always said between kisses jeanette
poured more the purplish liquor and they
drank this hail had no trouble
swallowing it
and he downed three tall glasses then
rose lifted jeanette in his arms carried
her
into the bedroom she was kissing the
side of his neck and it seemed to him an
electric charge was passing from
her lips to his skin up onto his brain
and down through his beating chest and
warming stomach and swelling
genital there's about as you know racy
as we get and on down through the soles
of his feet which strangely had become
ice
yet even in his ecstasy of anticipation
there was a stronghold
of retreat it was small but it was there
dark in the middle of the fire
there was also a black seed of panic
dropped by the doubt if he failed he
would kill himself he would be done
forever yet he told himself it could not
possibly happen must not
not when he had his arms around her and
her lips on his
he put her on the bed and then turned
off the ceiling light but she turned on
the lamp
over the bed why are you doing that he
said
standing at the foot of the bed feeling
the rise of panic and the fall of his
passion
at the same time he wondered how she
could so swiftly unseen by him have
unclothed herself
remember what you said told me the other
day the beautiful
passage god said let there be light we
do not need it
i do she says i must see you at every
moment the dark would take away half the
pleasure
i want to see you in love she reached
upward to adjust the angle of the bed
lamp her breasts rising with the
movement and sending an almost
intolerable pain through him
there now i can see your face especially
at the moment when i
will know best that you love me
right um and that's you know
again this is this is about the
sort of level of eroticism that's going
on it's actually quite romantic
you know um she kept her eyes wide open
throughout as if she were trying to
impress forever on every cell
of her body her lover's face right
she tells him be a lover you must love
me not rape me you can't take me because
i will surround you
so this is extraordinarily tame
right um there's there's actual
description going on but
not much i mean at one point uh nipples
are mentioned
uh you know breasts are talked about a
few times
but that's really it there's no like and
then you know his
his manhood penetrated her you know and
and she
heaved a sigh and orgasm or anything
like that as a matter of fact orgasm
only ends up getting mentioned in
clinical terms when
um hal's friend the the waggle bug is
explaining how the lolly thought works
so actual description not that much is
there really a breaking of the taboo
compared to
other authors i don't think so
as a matter of fact i will point out
that when i came to this story
reading it in the present having read
a lot of other philip jose farmer this
is extraordinarily
uh tame for for him right
what about sex being thematized okay so
you know it is a story called the lovers
there was
more of that emphasis in the original
publication
and a little bit less of the world
building a little bit less perhaps of
the story that's
that's being developed which is very
important a story about colonization
and forces opposing each other
it's really a story of hal
learning to overcome his you know
deep-seated repressions
and jeannette and him developing a
satisfactory
intimacy life which includes sex as part
of it but that's not
like it's it's not thematizing sex as in
saying
sex is front and center as the main
topic
in this as we will see in in later works
right
both by farmer and many other sci-fi
authors
so we come to the other thing in this
as we find at the very end other people
have
known this for a little while but hal
is completely in the dark about it he's
not having sex
with a human woman he thinks she's half
human
half human descended from french well a
french guy
who mated with the mammalian
human-like people of
the the planet oz again um
he discovers or rather it's told to him
that he has actually been having sex not
with an
insect as such but with a
pseudo pseudo-arthropod somewhat in some
respects like
the waggle bugs who are there a
different
not just species but type of of
living being and that's supposed to be
problematic as a matter of fact we see
that the
uh members of of the starch you know
find this disgusting you've laying with
an insect you know uh it's worse than
than laying with a a beast of the field
they've got this sort of biblical
approach to it
or rather let's call it you know old
school very repressed biblical approach
to it and um the woggle bug
and you know their entire culture they
don't really have a problem with this
then again they're not particularly
repressed
and hal himself turns out to be
fine with it unfortunately jeanette did
not
trust him enough because of his
repression to
tell him about it while they were
involved
and getting to know each other and
becoming intimate and having sex and
eventually
impregna well not quite impregnating her
she's already impregnated impressing
his genes visually upon the
ova um within her
so that's the part i think that
probably people were reacting against
and we could ask ourselves in our own
time
is this really that big of a deal
in in sci-fi or in even you know any
sort of fiction
i mean we have cartoons these days where
we have all sorts of characters who are
carrying on
love lives and doesn't just have to be a
mouse with a mouse you know
all at disney or something like that
there's there's all sorts of varieties
we are having discussions about
you know um what we're gonna do with sex
robots we
uh have all sorts of you know i mean
captain kirk kind of blew the lid open
on having sex with aliens himself and it
wasn't that big of a deal by the time
that
they got to him so i i think that
perhaps when we talk about the taboo the
taboo is actually
something rather confused the referent
is easy to bring up it's a single word
but what was actually off limits
and was the lovers the first to actually
bring up this idea
of humans and aliens no because ciel
morshamblo
uh is already introducing that she's a
different species
you know so i think that you know we can
talk about there
being a taboo but we probably have to be
much more careful in thinking about what
this really means
and the degree to which the lovers has
a real taboo to be the first story to
break
we might want to see it rather as an
important point within
a much broader set of developments
within the world
of english speaking science fiction
you